[Music]
the lenny lenape claimed the honor of
having received and welcomed the
europeans on their first arrival in the
country
situated between new england and
virginia it is probable however
that the mahikhani or mohicans who then
inhabited the banks of the hudson
concurred in the hospitable act
the relation i'm going to make was taken
down many years since
from the mouth of a great delaware
indian
and may be considered as a correct
account of the traditions existing among
them
of this momentous event
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
magellan has been an excellent supporter
of content from my brother and i for a
while now
they provide high quality context for
our videos
and this week's recommendation is no
exception pocahontas and john
smith love and survival in the new world
is a fascinating exploration of the
truth behind the romance
and what life was really like for those
first settlers
it's a great choice to follow up this
video magellan is always a great choice
if you want more context for our videos
whether it be voices of the past history
time or our new channel
the entire history of the earth magellan
is a sort of bingeable netflix for
documentaries
it has the widest range of history
content available anywhere
among lots of other genres for example
space many available
in high quality 4k click on the link in
the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers thanks
a great many years ago when men with a
white skin had never yet been seen in
this land
some indians who were out fishing had a
place where the sea
widens spied at a great distance
something remarkably large floating on
the water
and such as they had never seen before
these indians immediately returned to
the shore apprise their countrymen of
what they had observed
and pressed them to go out and discover
what it might be
they hurried out together and saw with
astonishment
the phenomenon which now appeared to
their sight but could not agree
upon what it was
some believed it to be an uncommonly
large fish or animal
while others were of the opinion it must
be a very big house
floating on the sea at length the
spectators concluded
that this wonderful object was moving
towards the land
and that it must be an animal or
something else that had life
in it it would therefore be proper to
inform
all the indians on the inhabited islands
of what they had seen and put them
on their guard
[Music]
accordingly they sent off a number of
runners and watermen
to carry the news to their scattered
chiefs that they might send off in every
direction for the warriors
with a message that they should come on
immediately these arriving in numbers
and having themselves viewed the strange
appearance
and observing that it was actually
moving towards the entrance of the river
or bay
concluded it to be a remarkably large
house
in which the menito himself was present
and that he probably was coming to visit
them
by this time the chiefs were assembled
at york island
and deliberating in what manner in which
they should receive the monito on his
arrival
every measure was taken to be well
provided with plenty of meat for
sacrifice
the women were desired to prepare the
best rituals
and the grand dance was decided not only
to be an agreeable entertainment for the
great being
but it was believed that it might with
the addition of a sacrifice
contribute to appease him if he was
angry with them
the conjurers were also set to work to
determine what this phenomenon pretended
and what the possible result of it might
be to these
and to the chiefs and wise men of the
nations men
women and children were looking up to
for advice
and protection distracted between hope
and fear
they were at a loss as to what to do a
dance however
commenced in great confusion
while in this situation fresh runners
arrived
declaring it to be a large house of
various colours
and crowded with living creatures it
appeared now to be certain
that it is the great manito bringing
them some kind of game
such as he had not given them before but
other runners soon after arrive declare
that it is positively a house
full of human beings of quite a
different color from that of the indians
and dressed differently from them then
in particular one of them was dressed
entirely
in red who must be the monito
himself
[Music]
they are hailed from the vessel in a
language they do not understand yet they
shout out or yell and return by way of
answer
according to the custom of the country
many offer running off to go to the
woods
but are pressed by others to stay in
order not to give offence to their
visitor
who might find them out and destroy them
the house
some say large canoe at last stops
and a canoe of smaller size comes on
shore with the red man
and some others in it some stay with his
canoe and guard it
the chiefs and wise men assembled in
council
form themselves into a large circle
towards which the man in red clothes
approaches with two others
he salutes them with a friendly
countenance and they return the salute
after their manner they are lost in
admiration
the dress the manners the whole
appearance of the unknown strangers
is to them a subject of wonder but they
are particularly struck with him
who wore the red coat all glittering
with gold lace
which they could in no manner account
for he
surely must be the great manito but why
should he have a white skin
meanwhile a large hack hack is brought
by one of his servants
from which an unknown substance is
poured out into a small couple glass
and handed to the supposed manito he
drinks
has the glass filled again and hands it
to the chief standing next to him
the chief receives it but only smells
the contents
and passes it on to the next chief who
does the same
the glass or cup then passes through the
circle without the liquor being tasted
by anyone
and is upon the point of being returned
to the red cloth monito
when one of the indians a brave man and
a great warrior
suddenly jumps up and harangues the
assembly on the impropriety of returning
the cup
with its contents
it was handed to them says he by the
monito
that they should drink out of it as he
himself had done
to follow his example would be pleasing
to him but to return what he had given
them
might provoke his wrath and bring
destruction on them
and since the orator believed it for the
good of the nation that the contents
offered them should be drunk and as no
one else would do it
he would drink it himself let the
consequence be what it might
it was better for one man to die than
that the whole nation should be
destroyed
he then took the glass and bidding the
assembly of solemn farewell
he at once drank up its whole contents
every eye was fixed on the resolute
chief to see what effect the unknown
liquor would produce
he soon began to stagger and at last
fell prostrate on the ground
his companions now bemoan his fate he
falls into a sound sleep and they think
he has expired he wakes again
jumps up and declares that he has
enjoyed the most delicious sensations
and that he has never before felt
himself so happy
as after he had drunk the cup he asks
for more
his wishes granted the whole assembly
then imitate him
and all become intoxicated
after this general intoxication had
ceased for they say that while it lasted
the whites would confine themselves to
their vessel the man with the red
clothes returned again
and distributed presents among them
consisting of beads
axes hoes and stockings such as those
the white people wear
they soon became familiar with each
other and began to converse by signs
the dutch made them understand that they
would not stay here but would pay them
another visit
the next year when they would bring them
more presents and stay with them a while
but as they could not live without
eating they should want a little land
they went away as they had said and
returned in the following
season when both parties were much
rejoiced to see each other
but the whites laughed at the indians
seeing that they knew not the use of the
axes and hoes that they had given them
the year before
four they had these things hanging to
their breasts as ornaments
and the stockings were made use of as
tobacco pouches
the whites now put handles on the former
for them and cut trees down before their
eyes
hold up the ground and put the stockings
on their legs
here they say a general laughter ensued
among the indians
they took every white man they saw for
an inferior manito attendant
upon the supreme deity who shone
superior in the red and laced clothes
as the whites became daily more familiar
with the indians they at last
proposed to stay with them and asked
only for so much ground for a garden
spot
as they said the hide of a bullock would
cover or encompass
which hyde was spread before them
the indians readily granted this
apparently reasonable request
but the whites then took a knife and
beginning at one end of the hide
cut it up to a long rope not thicker
than the child's finger
so that by the time the hole was cut up
it made a great heap
they then took the rope at one end and
drew it gently along
carefully avoiding its breaking it was
drawn out into a circular form
and being closed at its ends encompassed
a large piece of ground
the indians were surprised at the
superior wit of the whites
but did not wish to contend with them
about a little land
as they had still enough themselves
they lived contentedly together for a
long time though the former from time to
time asked for more land
which was readily obtained and thus they
gradually proceeded higher up the
mahikinatuk
until the indians began to believe that
they would soon want
all their country which in the end
proved true
[Music]
you